- NASA's job is to do the research.
They are scientists.
They are not a lobbying organization.
They are not advocates.
They do the research, and
they hand it over to us,
the public, and they hand
it to our legislators
and the policy makers.
And in my opinion, it is
really the policy makers' job
and the legislators' job to protect us,
to protect humanity.
At a time like this when
they have the science,
they have the information.
And to not do so, shouldn't be tolerated.
And thankfully we have an
election on November sixth
where we can do the research
of who is addressing this issue
and elect them into office.
And if people are in
office not doing that work,
we can fire them.
And that is, in my opinion,
what we should be doing.
I mean we can--
(audience applauding)